m
matemático de profesión pero me
considero un artista de corazón
y quiero contarles cómo es que alguien
vinculado a una si es exacta como la
matemática se involucró en un área al
parecer
entendida como el arte porque para hacer
digamos que el arte actualmente no
conecta mucho con la gente entonces por
lo general las personas no entienden
mucho cuando van de una galería y ven
una obra de arte porque pues tienen sus
propios códigos
esos son los códigos que yo
apreciaba cuando era un estudiante
todavía
en el colegio
y que luego más tarde pues
provocaron una especie de shock en mi
cabeza
y pues actualmente ahora me dedico es
entonces quiero contarles un poco de mi
trabajo
todos seguramente han soñado o han
tenido pesadillas con esto cierto es el
famoso teorema de pitágoras
donde se encuentran dos catetos y una
hipotenusa podemos utilizar este teorema
que está presente en realidad en muchos
ámbitos
y también la naturaleza
así como ustedes por ejemplo yo me
extracciones con este tipo de resultados
de hecho hay libros donde uno puede
encontrar más de 500 pruebas distintas
sobre este resultado
pero más o menos a la edad de 11 años
descubrí un libro en el cual se
anunciaba un resultado similar al
teorema de pitágoras
que fue propuesto hace más de 300 años
por un abogado o sea ni siquiera era
matemático era un abogado de apellido
firman en pie
esa fue mi obsesión durante varios años
y esto es conocido como el último
teorema de fermat y de hecho cuando yo
estaba en secundaria
y alguien me contó que lo habían probado
en el 95 un matemático en nombre de
sandro él se había probado y de hecho la
prueba constaba de más de 100 páginas
que estaban colgadas en internet
y yo me preguntaba habrá sido formar
quien había dicho que lo había resuelto
ahora le habrán tomado el estás en mi
página
me preguntaban si era posible resolver
este tipo de problema con matemática
elemental
durante la universidad mi tiempo se
ocupaba en eso en tratar de resolver
y gracias a eso fue que me convertí en
el presidente podría restaurar
el instituto de ciencia
tienes
y luego pude viajar a argentina un
congreso de matemática donde estuvieron
presentes mis héroes o sea quienes
habían escrito en los libros que yo
llevaba todos los días a la universidad
ellos estuvieron presentes en este
congreso
y pude conocerlo y pude intercambiar
algunas palabras con ellos
pero en retrospectiva
algo que siempre recuerdo es que desde
niño siempre me gustaron ver las
imágenes que venían en las enciclopedias
por ejemplo esta es una obra de dalí muy
conocida
siempre me llamaron la atención estas
imágenes y creo que de alguna forma y
además digamos que ya más adelante en el
tiempo me di cuenta de que la razón por
la cual yo estudié matemáticas era
porque era el único curso donde podía
dibujar en geometría podría dibujar en
otro curso no podía y esa fue la razón
por la cual yo me interesé en las
matemáticas y descubrir todo este
universo lógico que está muy relacionado
con la naturaleza
estas fotos de hace 19 años hace 9 años
yo comencé a hacer investigación y iba a
congresos alrededor de todo el país
tratando de mostrar mis investigaciones
esto fue en chiclayo hace exactamente 9
años
y por eso entonces ya se ha hablado del
uso del poder computacional el uso de la
tecnología en el campo de las
matemáticas cómo utilizar tecnología
para poder hacer matemáticas
a esta etapa de mi vida y la denominada
regla
en ese momento yo estaba investigando
acerca de este mundo digamos matemático
que puede resultar tan complejo
pero sentía que no podía avanzar que
había una limitación tenía algunas
limitaciones es en ese momento que llegó
a argentina
y decidido los dos últimos días del
congreso decidió visitar la ciudad
conocer cómo era buenos aires y llegué a
visitar algunas zonas de hecho esta foto
es bien curiosa porque uno ve a
argentina como una ciudad buenos aires
una ciudad donde hay todo tipo de
culturas es un techo es un
y cuando voy a visitar el barrio de la
boca al lado del barrio de la boca hay
una galería que se llama el probador en
esta galería
cuando entró por primera vez descubre
una serie de obras que no tenían nada
que ver con las obras que yo conocía y
que había visto del arte clásico
obras que utilizaban por ejemplo
sensores avalarse espejos y yo me
preguntaba a qué rayos es esto esto es
qué es esto hasta ese momento mi vínculo
con el arte era más que todo es desde un
punto de vista de observador pero lo que
había visto era lo clásico como la
mayoría
descubrí que esta obra fue realizada en
el 71 por un argentino
luís benedictis
en el 71 ellos ya comenzaban a trabajar
con tecnología vinculada tecnología
ciencia y arte y me preguntaba qué pasa
en el perú porque me gustó no sé qué es
esto
yo soy web tengo del área de las
ciencias
y normalmente para mí lo que yo quiera
yo sentía que alguna forma compartida
con muchas experiencias estéticas igual
igual que con los poetas por ejemplo
porque un matemático para poder
demostrar un resultado pues pasa por
todo un proceso hasta que llega tras el
eureka el eureka de arquímides o la
epifanía en este caso que tiene un
artista
de alguna forma yo me sentía una artista
acción de matemáticas
al regresar a lima decidió tomarme un
descanso de esta investigación
y lo primero que hago es inscribirme en
un taller de poesía
dije piensan y me gusta escribir te voy
a meter un taller de poesía en este
taller de poesía seguramente me voy a
enseñar a pulir mi escritura mentira no
me enseñaron nada me enseñaron a hacer
páginas fuera
y ustedes se preguntarán qué tienen que
ver las estaciones web
con la poesía resulta que en los
setentas en los ochentas
los poetas comenzaron a experimentar con
la tecnología digital
hacían poemas que eran en realidad
ejecutables archivos ejecutables y
aprovechaban
algo que es súper importante en el
internet el uso del hipervínculo
cuando uno explora una página web puede
darles distintos recorridos a una página
web
por lo tanto uno podría aprovechar eso
en la poesía para dar distintas lecturas
a un pueblo
algo similar a lo que ocurre cuando uno
lee la rayuela de corta
la no linealidad es
distintas formas de leer algo
y darle nuevo significado a caras
lo siguiente que hago es meterme a un
taller de vídeo y resulta que en este
taller de vídeo me enseñan a programar
para hacer vídeos
usar líneas de código para hacer vídeos
y así ni bien comencé conozco una
persona que me lleva a trabajar al mundo
de las artes escénicas
y en él exactamente en el 2012 presentó
en la primera obra de artes escénicas de
danza contemporánea que usaba el sensor
kinect fue el que creo que es el primer
proyecto que utilizar kinect para
mapping interactivo y esto fue en el
2012 en el auditorio de la alianza
francesa
y hace varios años
ay pueden ver el mapping esto fue en el
frontis el estado
en la cabañita
puedo rescatar de esto que tuve que
aprender en un mes cómo lograr este
diálogo entre lo que proponían
artísticamente de las bailarinas y lo
que yo pocoyó y lo que yo podía proponer
como artista visual
lo siguiente que hago luego de hacer
esto
de meterme en el mundo de las artes
escénicas es comenzar a tratar de
encontrarme conmigo mismo unir puntos
como steve jobs
yo soy matemático y como matemático
debería utilizar matemáticas en mi
trabajo
entonces lo primero que comienza a hacer
es tratar de darle un sentido a las
matemáticas que había aprendido en el
colegio muchos hemos estudiado sobre la
mente de las funciones trigonométricas
no se lo conoce no tan caliente
contagien de esas cosas de vida y
siempre nos preguntamos eso para que nos
está sirviendo ahora
ahora estoy en mi vida estoy utilizando
el centro tiene sentido eso es algo que
yo me preguntaba
y de hecho lo que están viendo es una
aplicación de eso que están viendo se
forma con los hechos un vídeo
me di cuenta que mucha de la matemática
y lo aprendido se podría reutilizar en
estos procesos
todo el tiempo
esto fue digamos que uno de los momentos
más felices de mi vida porque luego de
comenzar a hacer este tipo de arte que
era utilizar matemáticas para generar
algunos ambientes experiencias nuevas
experiencias me di cuenta que yo podía
crear crear arte con matemáticas pero
arte que podía conectar con la gente de
hecho les voy a explicar esta imagen
esta imagen es increíble porque vemos a
un niño de no más de 10 años al lado de
un señor de más de 80 que eran dos
desconocidos que entraron a la calle a
la galería y comenzaron a interactuar
con mi obra
no tenía que contarles de que trataba la
obra no tenía que decirles cómo
interactuar con ella automáticamente se
pusieron a jugar entre ellos de hecho al
final se llevan la mano me di cuenta del
poder que tenía la tecnología y el arte
para poder lograr que dos sujetos
totalmente desconocidos puedan
participar
esto es algo hiperactivo
lo siguiente que hago luego de estar
involucrado pues en
en el mundo de las artes electrónicas
involucrarme en el mundo de los fab labs
de la fabricación digital entonces lo
que voy a mostrarles es mi proyecto del
curso de fabricación digital es un
diplomado internacional y lo que hice
fue un proyecto basado digamos en la
costumbre altoandina de la pasada de wii
porque porque mi familia provenía del
sur y de hecho yo visité muchas zonas
rurales y siempre me preguntaba cómo
poder ayudar a estas personas
lo que hice fue una plataforma móvil de
detección de enfermedades
con forma de wii
un robot cuadrúpedo
dice toda la parte electrónica toda la
parte mecánica y de hecho este proyecto
me llevó a ganar un premio en barcelona
el 2014 el premio win que es un fue uno
de los premios más prestigiosos en arte
y tecnología
fue porque fue fui el último en ganar la
última edición
y lo que yo hacía básicamente en hacer
lo que hace un laboratorista usamos la
técnica de baciloscopía para identificar
utilizando técnicas de visión
computacional procesamiento de imágenes
la presencia de bacterias 'mycobacterium
tuberculosis'
luego de esta aventura decido formar una
empresa lima may
el primer makers page abierto en un
laboratorio de cualquier persona voy a
entrar
y hacer sus sueños realidad porque eso
es lo que me interesa
a mí me interesa que las personas puedan
hacer sus sueños realidad puedan crear
mi filosofía de vida es creer y crear
entonces mi ideal era lograr que otras
personas puedan hacer lo mismo
luego me di cuenta por ejemplo de que en
cierta forma también me estaba
tradicional
porque me había ligado mucho
este mundo que era más práctico y había
perdido de vista mis orígenes que era
como científico como matemático entonces
lo siguiente que hago es regresar de
nuevo a la academia y comenzar a hacer
investigación dentro de la academia tuve
que dejar a un lado
últimamente
pero igual como uno tiene siempre curar
es que uno prueba esta sensación esta
adrenalina de poder desarrollar
proyectos siempre valientes
lo siguiente que hice luego de estar en
la academia es dar un giro de 180 grados
en mi vida y meterme al tanto
corporativo
fundamos algunos amigos un
emprendimiento una empresa
del centro diseño de productos y diseño
de servicios
sin tener mucha experiencia en eso
más que por el lado creativo de utilizar
mis manos para fabricar cosas o para
idear comenzamos a trabajar con grandes
marcas
comenzamos a rediseñar servicios aprendí
un montón de este trabajo
pero lo más importante lo que más
rescato es que aprendí a empatizar me di
cuenta que había una falta empatía entre
eminem la ciudad y que será una de las
razones por las cuales todavía muchos
problemas seguían siendo sordos
aprendí mucho
en paralelo sevilla con estos proyectos
de arte usando matemáticas para mostrar
que el que yo podía trabajar estos
campos del arte de la tecnología y la
ciencia en paralelo
poder crear paisajes invisibles perdón o
paisajes que no existían que solo que
sólo estaban en mi cabeza
hasta que surge la posibilidad de poder
trabajar
con marilyn y partner en un proyecto que
se llama touring y en el cual comenzamos
a utilizar el arte y la tecnología para
lograr que niños con asperger puedan
desarrollar habilidades comunicativas
ese fue uno de los primeros proyectos
que me comenzó a cambiar la vida
proyectos más vinculados al área social
pero que usaban el arte el potencial que
tiene el arte el poder que tiene el arte
para poder conectar a las personas pero
a través de la tecnología porque todos
estamos de alguna forma muy vinculados a
la tecnología
acá podemos ver algunas de las cosas que
ellos hacían
y lo siguiente que hago es meterme en
otro proyecto en otro emprendimiento que
se llama agua pero ya saliendo de lima
ya en chiclayo donde usamos la
tecnología para poder capacitar a
mujeres en tecnología y ellos pueden
desarrollar su propio emprendimiento de
base tecnológica por ejemplo
la historia de la señora flor de más de
50 años que aprendió a soldar y aprendió
hacer sus propias placas electrónicas
a mí me partió el corazón cuando vi que
fue la alumna más aplicada de un grupo
de chicas que oscilaban entre los 17
años y los 50 no a los 60
luego comenzamos a hacer capacitaciones
con fábula
fuera de lima y de hecho esto está fue
una de las experiencias más
gratificantes que tuve porque fui a
chimbote y puede dar un taller de
fabricación digital del uso de impresión
3d
porque cuando me invitaron a ser ponente
en un evento de tecnología vi que sus
estudiantes de últimos ciclos usaban
palitos de chupete para prototipar sus
proyectos y eso me partió el corazón
con agua acabamos de ganar hace un mes
el premio protagonistas del cambio de
upc
y lo que les he contado son una serie de
proyectos que realmente están vinculados
al arte a la ciencia y la tecnología
porque en realidad no deberíamos no
deberíamos pensar que estas áreas están
que son ajenas no debemos creer eso como
una reflexión final
quiero decirles o quiero transmitirles
mi mantra mi mantra es creer y crear
creer porque si nosotros no creemos
nadie más va a creer en nosotros tenemos
que crear con todas nuestras fuerzas
para lograr que nuestros objetivos se
puedan cumplir que lo que pensamos
ocurra suceda y crear porque tenemos que
crear el mundo en el cual queremos vivir
tenemos que hacerlo nosotros mismos
gracias por haberme escuchado soy my
colorado
[Aplausos]